[Music]
hi
my name is fergal ward i'm the founder
of
capri medical when we looked at the
migraine market
we saw that it's the third most common
disease
it's the seventh most debilitating
disease
uh globally there's one billion people
who suffer from
from the migraine there wasn't a
consistent efficacy
of drug treatment for chronic pain
patients
so we looked at this and we said we said
there has to be a better solution
we were one of the first companies to be
awarded
um an eic blended
finance award and so that
included um
almost seven seven million euros 2.4
million
euros in grant and then 4.5
million euros in eic equity
as well
[Music]
we've had some great introductions into
some of the
investors on the portal and we can
continue to
um to communicate with those
the portal has been a fantastic resource
you know some of the providing access
to um investors that you just would not
have heard about
and then we've also had a direct
one-on-one introductions to investors
from the portal and from the team
as well so that's been amazing
you